it's party time and I'm told by the  Davos groupies the ones here a pretty  epic and they do my best to get you  inside one and yes taking these with me  the things I do for Annenberg TV turn  that music off so a couple of parties on  the menu tonight one at the Belvedere  Hotel another on the piano bar and  another at the see Horford sale and I'm  going to do my best to get you into one  here goes  no invite no entry so it's kind of like  being 14 and trying to get into a pub  you know you look like Harry Potter but  you try anyway  now for the positive  that's a no off to the Java  piano bar behind me let's do this I'm  not sure my name is on the list Johnson  Thoreau  okay success now I'm off to find that  free bar